[Music]
hi I'm Jennifer Evans Carrio the
president of sugar spend marketing
author of Pinterest marketing an hour a
day and the social media faculty chair
at market motive thanks for joining me
for the wrap-up in our series on
Facebook Ads
today we're going to be talking about
the various targeting options that
facebook gives you as you're actually
going through the promoted post or
Facebook advertising section one of the
things that makes Facebook advertising
so popular among marketers is it's one
of the few places where you really have
the ability to target down on such a
granular level from different
demographics and interests that you can
really make sure your ad is going out to
the people who are the absolute most
likely to engage with or interact with
it so currently facebook offers more
than a dozen ways to target everything
from age and gender to location to
educational status or current employer
tons and tons of different ways to do
this now the nice thing about Facebook's
targeting option is the targeting screen
that you go through while you're
building your advertising campaign does
a wonderful job of walking you through
each of your options and showing you
what happens is you make some of those
adjustments so when we look at the left
side of the screen we see things like
audience location age gender interest we
can see how we work our way through one
section at a time determining what our
specific targeting is going to be to a
narrower audience when we look at the
right side of the screen this is where
we see a continually updated audience
definition and what this section is
going to do is every layer of targeting
that you add on it's going to put into
this box to let you know exactly what
set of people you're targeting and it's
going to change that potential reach
number to reflect the actual amounts of
people that are within the Facebook user
system that match the demographics
you've set up so if you're a large
company and you're looking to reach
millions of people based on perhaps you
know wider geographical range or broader
interests you can do that if you're a
smaller company or you're laser
targeting one of your specific campaign
and you want to take it down to
something that targets you know 1,500 or
3,000 people you can do that as well and
again Facebook will give you a continual
update on what those targeting numbers
are looking like now the three biggest
forms of targeting that we're going to
see in Facebook are going to be things
like location so again this might be a
country based location it might be a
state based location or if you're doing
a specific campaign for a
brick-and-mortar store or maybe for an
events that you have that's taking place
in a physical location you can go right
down to the zip codes and this is a
really effective way again to laser
target even just your messaging and on
to the people that are in that specific
area there's also the option to come in
and go by age so perhaps you're a law
school and you're looking for current
undergrads or people coming back as a
second career student you might want to
have two different sets of age targeting
that are going to have different
promotional texts and different focus
within the ad so most companies know
what their generalized demographics are
in terms of who they're targeting age
wise but again there's different
messaging and different sales points
that we send to different sets of people
and this is a great way to be able to
target that then of course the idea of
gender if you're targeting something
different to men than you are to women
you have the ability to come in and
narrow the field down to one or the
other or again to come in and write up
two different types of ads that are
based to the two different genders now
there's also the idea of interest
targeting the interesting thing about
interest targeting on Facebook is that
you can start with sort of their
generalized created topics these tend to
be very broad in general I don't
recommend them for any but the largest
companies trying to do the largest level
of branding campaigns but they do work
really well as an idea source because
you can click on some of the individual
categories and expand it out see what
else is included within that area you
can also start to type in that keywords
or phrases and basically run searches to
see what topics are going to have a
match so again if we go with our idea of
law schools and we start to type in
something like law school
well maybe we want an ad that's targeted
at a law school admission test you know
maybe at law schools in the United
States or in a specific area of the
United States
and we can pick up some people on that
so typing slowly because again once you
get past a specific word or phrase it's
not going to pop up as many suggestions
but typing slowly and kind of scanning
the list to see what's there can be a
really good way build out your list with
some of the ideas you might not have
thought of on your own and then once
you've started to put some of these in
place Facebook is also going to offer up
some suggestions that are based on the
selections you've made if you're
promoting a wedding site and you've
started clicking things that are related
to rustic weddings or Barn weddings
they're going to pick up more phrases
like that you know antique wedding
decorations things like that that
they're going to recommend to you
so again Facebook does a pretty good job
once we start to narrow the field of the
helping us narrow it a little bit
further now there's also the idea of
connection targeting so this is where
you're going to start looking at are you
pushing your message out to people who
are already connected with you are you
trying to go after a new audience that
hasn't connected with you yet or are you
trying to leverage the connections you
already have in order to reach sort of
the friend of a friend group so when we
look at the connected options you can
narrow this down to your contacts where
you can exclude that context which is a
very very good idea to do if you're
trying to actually build your reach you
know or do a special promotion in an
attempt to get more people in to follow
you some of the advanced targeting
that's going to allow you to market to
people who may have liked specific pages
that you're engaged with maybe they have
attended or liked or RSVP'd a specific
event that you have hosted so again if
you're coming back and targeting next
year's event you may want to go after
the people who connected with you on the
previous year's event listings on your
Facebook page then there's also the idea
of again friend targeting going after
that friend of a friend pulling off the
existing credibility of saying hey this
person that you know is connected to our
brand there's a good chance that you're
going to want to be as well another form
of targeting that facebook offers up is
relationship status so one you can look
at it from the front of sexuality you
know that men interested in women men
interested in men you know women
interested in men vice versa so the
whole combination of things so if you
want to target for
to say political purposes or for a cause
if you want to put up lifestyle ads that
match that specific demographic whether
it's using specific imaging or specific
word choices you have the ability to do
that layer of targeting there's also the
idea of going after the overall
relationship status you may want to
target an engaged person in a different
way that you might target a person who's
married or a person who's single
because engaged people are typically at
a different stage of their life and that
they're looking for different products
and there's different things you might
want to offer out to them so again the
creative targeting that can come into
play when you look at this combination
you know the ad that you might show to a
woman who's engaged to a man for jewelry
might be different than the ad that you
show to a man who's engaged to a man you
know for jewelry or for something else
so looking at how that combination can
go together and how you choose to market
your specific products can lend a lot of
potential options here just on the
relationship status alone now there's
also the idea of education and work
targeting so let's say you're doing a
campaign where you're interested in
targeting grabs for internships that are
from a specific school that's near your
physical location you have the ability
to narrow the field to people who were
in college at that specific school right
down to the field of study that they've
actually put into place so sometimes
that's going to be targeting people for
somewhere down the road because you've
got someone who's in college or in high
school and you're trying to pull them
into a specific career path or sometimes
it's shorter term prospects because
maybe you're looking to hire maybe
you're looking to connect with or maybe
you're offering continued education
credits to specific people with this
specific background or educational focus
there's also the idea of targeting again
the specific schools and majors just
based on what you know you're trying to
accomplish are you trying to sell alumni
gear to people from the particular
colleges that might have made the
national championship game and
basketball or in football do you want to
come in and do this level of targeting
right down to the graduation years if
you found you've got a higher conversion
rate off of some of those specific years
then again the idea of specific
workplaces because if you are targeting
especially on the b2b side there's a lot
of potential to say well we know people
that work at this specific company
probably
have this specific need and to be able
to go in and laser target that way so
the great thing about Facebook is once
you've gone through this whole process
and you've really thought about you know
your customer personas who you're
looking to reach out to what your
messaging is going to look like you can
start to build these ultra targeted
lists so the example we have here we
were putting something together for a
specific law school that was located in
the southern part of the country and
they knew their target states are going
to be Alabama and Florida and Georgia
we're looking for a specific age group
who are interested in postgraduate
education but we're currently in college
we could pick out the majors that we
knew were most common for people who
were entering law school we could pick
out the couple of years that we're going
to be the best fit because our specific
ad was going to be in English we could
target people who were speaking either
UK or us English and all of a sudden
we've gone from the one point you know
five billion people on Facebook down to
66 hundred people that are laser
targeted and then we can go back and do
additional targeting groups that are
going to carry slightly different
messaging because again we want to match
that ad that we're putting out there
with the people we're trying to get it
in front of now along with targeting one
of the other really nice features that
facebook offers that used to only be
part of Facebook exchange but has now
been expanded out to all levels of
Facebook users is this idea of custom
audiences and basically what custom
audiences allows you to do is take an
existing list of email addresses that
your business has and use it to build
something even better
so when you're setting up your Facebook
ad and you're in your targeting area
there's a section at the very top that
says audience that section has a link
that says create new audience when you
click on that link what Facebook is
going to allow you to do is either
upload a data file that you have stored
somewhere or if you happen to use
MailChimp you're going to have the
opportunity to simply sync your
MailChimp account with Facebook and to
pull the data in that way so when you
choose this option and it goes out and
it lets you pick which account you have
set up in MailChimp or you know which
account you have setting on your hard
drive that has your data fields it'll
take a little while for it to pop up and
actually be ready to use but what it
will do is it will go through that list
of email addresses and it will scrub
that list to look for the
dresses that are also associated with
Facebook accounts now your list is not
going to come over at a hundred percent
because a lot of people have multiple
accounts they use different accounts for
different purposes but there does
usually tend to be a pretty reasonable
amount of crossover between the email
addresses that end up on lists and the
email addresses that are used for
Facebook accounts so once you do that
then when you go back in to building
your campaign you're going to have that
drop-down list showing up as part of
your audience where you can say here's
the specific list from MailChimp or from
my hard drive that I've uploaded and you
can use that as your actual starting
point so by using that as your starting
point you have the opportunity to either
start with that list and then use
Facebook's targeting to add additional
layers on top of it or to use that list
to exclude from any promo that you do so
let's say you're putting out a special
offer for new users and you don't want
it to show up for anyone that's already
in your customer base you can upload
that list of email addresses and you can
use that to scrub those people from
Facebook and not have your ad actually
show up for them or again you can go in
and you can on the more positive side
you know narrow the field a little more
using all the demographic targeting that
facebook offers now it's important to
keep in mind that there is a minimum
reach to use both targeting in general
on Facebook but also to use the custom
audiences so if you're a small company
you have a very small email list you're
not really going to be able to go in and
laser target your list even further
because if you have fewer than a
thousand people after your targeting
Facebook's not actually going to allow
you to run the list now that said a list
of any size can be used for exclusion so
it's important to remember it on that
front that even if you are a small
company you have the ability to come in
and say okay but I want to send ads to
people who aren't on my list now if
you're an enterprise-level company and
you want to come in and use your mailing
list and laser target based on those
demographics to fine tune the specific
ad you're sending out to each group of
people custom audiences is a wonderful
thing to allow you to do that now just a
couple you know ideas and maybe bits of
inspiration on why you would use custom
audio
because well some people say sure it's
great that I can upload that list and do
something from it you know help me
understand what that looks like so if we
go back to the example used earlier of a
law school and we're looking to build up
the followers maybe we want to come in
and we want to upload the list of email
addresses we have that are associated
with our students maybe we want to
upload another list of prospective
students and another list of faculty and
that's going to allow us to exclude the
current fans of our Facebook page while
targeting each of those three email
lists in an attempt to boost our
followers up now there's also the idea
of wanting to sell something maybe you
have a specific event that you're trying
to promote registrations for maybe a
study guide that you're looking to put
out so again excluding some of the
current fans well using that list as a
starting point to target to say okay we
can obviously use our Facebook page to
push the messages out and do promoted
posts but we have this whole other group
of people that were connected with that
don't follow us on Facebook and being
able to build custom audiences out of
those lists and being able to do that
targeted marketing in that Facebook side
of the web can be really handy for
companies and then finally the simple
idea of just increasing your exposure
you know if you're sending out an ad
using email marketing and you want to
take that same list and show that same
ad to that same person when they get on
Facebook as well in a form of you know
retargeting there's the opportunity to
do that by uploading those custom
audience lists so it's a great way to
reinforce those email marketing efforts
by matching your Facebook Ads to what
you're doing elsewhere thank you so much
for joining me for this series on
Facebook advertising
[Music]
Hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn Channel and click here to watch
more such videos to nerd up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here